let's go to the United States now where
Republicans have won the House of
Representatives after last week's
midterm elections and the result gives
the party the power to block Joe Biden's
agenda for the final two years of his
presidency
but Biden's party the Democrats
maintained their narrow Senate majority
dashing Republican hopes of controlling
both chambers of Congress
victory for Republicans who have taken
control of the U.S House of
Representatives but with the wind narrow
in their majority slim legislating and
governing could prove difficult
power in Congress is now split with
Democrats in control of the Senate
U.S President Joe Biden signaled his
willingness for cooperation stating I
congratulate leader McCarthy on his
house majority and am ready to work
together for American families
Republican house leader Kevin McCarthy
is tipped to become house Speaker one of
the most powerful positions in
Washington ahead of the house win the
congressman from California won the
nomination from his party
I told you we'd get back just took a
little while well good evening I'm proud
to announce the era of one party
Democrat rule in Washington is over
Washington now has a check and balance
the American people have a say in their
government and this new Republican
leadership team is ready to get to work
to put America back on the right track
that track will likely include trying to
cut government spending and tighten
border security
McCarthy has vowed to investigate the
U.S withdrawal from Afghanistan and the
finances of the president's son Hunter
Biden
Republicans now have the power to oppose
the president's agenda for the final
years of his term but the President also
has a veto over legislation proposed by
the Congress House Republicans will also
have the next presidential elections in
2024 in mind when it comes to their
legislative decisions McCarthy is close
to former president Donald Trump who has
just announced his bid for a second
presidential term
America's comeback starts right now
but with many Republicans blaming Trump
for the parties worse than expected
performance in the midterms McCarthy may
want to put some political distance
between himself and the former president
and I'm always very pleased to welcome
Stacey Bivins into the studio for
analysis Stacy put this into perspective
for us how much power have the
Republicans gained by getting majority
in the House of Representatives well I
guess it depends on what they've learned
from this election Independents and
young people broke hard for the
Democrats they care about abortion
rights they care about the environment
they care about democracy and so as in
this piece that just aired we we heard
the talk of an investigation of Hunter
Biden well that's a loser for a lot of
Voters in the U.S they want to know how
they're going to be able to pay for for
food how they're going to be able to pay
for gas and so these kinds of issues are
a loser for the Republican party and and
just to be clear
there were so many candidates who were
presented by Donald Trump where they
were relitigating the 2020 election and
where they were talking about these
culture War issues voters said enough we
want to see people work together to make
America better but our Republicans
United on this issue they have a
majority but it is it is a narrow
majority it was a narrow Victory do you
think the party will be able to unite to
get its policies passed the problem is
the the majority that they have is so
slim that it's almost a win for the
Democrats and so what let me just play
this out for you so we have the
Republicans and they're split half of
the party supports Trump and they
have a more of what people feel like is
a hard-line view and then you have other
people who say you know what the
Republican party has gone off course so
it's going to be harder for the
Republican leader in the house to get
his team together the Democrats are
mostly United especially in the house
but in the but with the Republicans it's
going to be a harder task right and what
will this then mean for President
Biden's legislative agenda
well he's made it very clear that he
thinks that what he's done in the past
two years is a win and so he wants to
keep going
um with that but of course he's going to
have some roadblocks because
of the way that the this has played out
with the legislature going to the um
Republicans but like I said it's not an
easy victory for the Republicans because
they don't necessarily have the numbers
because they don't have the unification
okay well now that Biden of the
Democrats won't control both houses of
Congress do you think it's possible that
we will see the president focusing more
on foreign policy which is traditionally
an area where the executive branch has
more power sure I mean he wants the U.S
to be a leader when it comes to the
climate
um and so yes he wants to be able to
show that the the United States is a
partner that their foreign allies can
depend on so that's something that he's
definitely going to be pushing for in
the months and years ahead all right
thank you so much for that that's Stacy
Bivens with our election team good to
see you Claire
for more I'm joined by bojas Forman a
professor of politics at Bart College
Berlin Boris put this into perspective
for us how much power has the Republican
party got on it
well now what we're seeing after two
years of United government is a divided
government which means that basically we
heard this budgetary questions cannot be
decided very easily we saw that in the
first two years even with both Chambers
in the hands of the Democrats it wasn't
easy but now of course the Republicans
if the past is any indication will
probably have a very destructive agenda
of trying to undermine any any
legislative agenda that Biden might
still have
how United are the Republicans though in
in trying to undermine the Democrats
well I mean
laws are made in Congress the Senate is
still with the uh with the Democrats but
Republicans will not or probably it's
very unlikely for them to join in any
legislative proposals I mean we saw one
exception just two months ago or three
months ago the chips act which was
mostly about protecting manufacturing at
home we also saw some bipartisan uh
proposals when it came to
the the Tariff conflicts with China so
in military questions foreign policy
questions economic questions who knows
maybe there might still be something on
the agenda that might work but it's
quite unlikely because the presidential
election 2024 is coming up and the
Republicans will try to to portray Biden
as a weak president
what about foreign policy that's usually
something where uh even a lame duck
president can have more room for
maneuver
right I think this is the two there are
two Dimensions to this one is the as you
say the foreign policy Dimension uh
where we'll certainly also given the
historical moment and the war in Ukraine
and the shifting uh tectonic shifts in
global relationships also with China
we'll certainly see more of that uh by
Biden and at the same time I think we'll
see more executive orders at home this
is something that Obama had already done
against a Congress that was also trying
to block all types of legislative
proposals and Trump himself as well has
used many executive orders it's become
the the tool of choice in a heavily
polarized political society and he's
also announced his plans to run for
president thank you very much for the
analysis